in front of the White House we're
standing in DC letting the world know
that we still exist our revolution is
not dick people have been suffering for
four years
owing on to our fifth year and I recall
as Obama said that if Assad crosses the
red line that he will intrude and see
action but Assad has played jump rope
with the red line at this point
the US shouldn't be doing ending the war
in Syria they should be helping Syrians
to end the war in Syria with no more
fighter jets no more helicopters in the
sky it's a free people Syria are able to
take out Isis and pick out the regime is
brought down in whose regime and Isis is
kicked out Isis an exit are the same the
only difference is the name President
Obama wants to degrade and destroy the
Islamic state and now the United States
is set to train and fund a select group
of